it was New Year's Eve 2019 when health
officials in China admitted they had a
problem the health authorities have
activated them a serious response level
after an outbreak of a new type of viral
pneumonia in central China a rapidly
growing number of people were developing
a dry cough and fever before getting
pneumonia and for some it turned fatal
doctors have named the disease kovat 19
or coronavirus disease 20 19 indicating
that a type of virus is causing illness
when they try to trace its origin they
found a likely source this food market
in Wuhan over the first 41 patients 27
had been here it wasn't conclusive
evidence but Chinese officials quickly
shut down the market they had seen this
happen before at a place just like this
the health officials are trying to get a
grip on an alarming outbreak of SARS the
virus originated in mainland China has
spread across the country the disease
have been festering for months in
southern China in 2002 a corona virus
had emerged at a very similar market in
southern China it eventually reached 29
countries and killed nearly 800 people
now 18 years later this corona virus is
in at least 71 countries and has already
killed over 3,100 people so what do
these markets have to do with the corona
virus outbreak and why is it happening
a lot of the viruses that make us sick
actually originate in animals some of
the viruses that cause the flu come from
birds and pigs hiv/aids comes from
chimpanzees the deadly Ebola virus
likely originates in bats and in the
case of the 2019 corona virus there's
some evidence it went from a bat to a
Pangolin before infecting a human while
viruses are very good at jumping between
species it's rare for a deadly one to
make this journey all the way to humans
that's because it would need all these
hosts to encounter each other at some
point that's where the wuhan market
comes in it's a wet market a kind of
place where live animals are slaughtered
and sold for consumption it was not
surprised at all and I think that it was
not surprise to many scientists Peter
Lee is a professor and expert on China's
animal trade the cages stack about one
over another animals at the bottom were
are often soaked with all kinds of
liquid animal excrement tasks that are
what literally could be receiving from
the animals that's exactly how a virus
can jump from one animal to another if
that animal then comes in contact with
or is consumed by human the virus could
potentially infect them and if the virus
then spreads to other humans it causes
an outbreak what markets are scattered
all over the world but the ones in China
are particularly well known because they
offer a wide variety of animals
including wildlife this is a sample menu
reportedly from the market in Wuhan
these animals are from all over the
world and each one has the potential to
carry its own viruses to the market the
reason all these animals are in the same
market is because of a decision china's
government made decades ago back in the
1970s china was falling apart famine had
killed more than 36 million people and
the communist regime which controlled
all food production was failing to feed
its more than 9
million people in 1978 on the verge of
collapse the regime gave up this control
and allowed private farming while large
companies increasingly dominated the
production of popular foods like pork
and poultry some smaller farmers turned
to catching and raising wild animals as
a way to sustain themselves after their
beginning it was mostly peasant
household backyard operation of the
turtles for example that la-la-la family
started to get off the grounds and since
it started to feed and sustain people
the Chinese government backed it so it
was imperative for the government to
encourage people to you know to make the
liggins through whatever productive
activities they can fund them servant
even lift yourself out of a poverty no
matter what you are doing that's ok but
then in 1988 the government made a
decision that changed the shape of
wildlife trade in China they enacted the
wildlife protection law which designated
the animals as resources owned by the
state and protected people engaged in
the utilization of wildlife resources
that's one of the most devastating
problems of the law because either you
designate the wildlife as the natural
resource the music is something you can
use for human benefits the law also
encouraged the domestication and
breeding a wild life and with that an
industry was born small local farms
turned into industrial sized operations
for example this bear farm started with
just three and eventually grew to more
than a thousand bears bigger populations
meant greater chances that a sick animal
could spread disease farmers were also
raising a wide variety of animals which
meant more viruses on the farms
nonetheless these animals were funneled
into the wet markets for profit
while this legal wildlife farming
industry started booming it
simultaneously provided cover for an
illegal wildlife industry endangered
animals like tigers were on US forces
and pangolins were trafficked into China
by the early 2000s these markets were
teeming with wild animals when the
inevitable happened
the latest on the deadly SARS virus the
worldwide death toll up again today
China has reported more than 1400 cases
of infection nationwide it is what
health officials have feared all along
in 2003 the SARS outbreak was traced to
a wet market here in southern China
scientists found traces of the virus and
farmed civet cats Chinese officials
quickly shut down the markets and banned
wildlife farming but just a few months
after the outbreak the Chinese
government declared 54 species of
wildlife animals including civet cats
legal to farming it by 2004 the wildlife
farming industry was worth an estimated
100 billion won and it exerted
significant influence over the Chinese
government type in China's gigantic GDP
but the industry has the enormous Lobby
capability it's because of this
influence that the Chinese government
has allowed these markets to grow over
the years in 2016 for example the
government sanctioned the farming of
some endangered species like tigers and
pangolins by 2018 the wildlife industry
had grown to 148 billion won and had
developed clever marketing tactics to
keep the markets around the industry has
been promoting you know these wildlife
animals as in atonic products as you
know bodybuilding as sex enhancing and
of course as a disease fighting none of
the claims can hold water yet these
products became popular with an
influential portion of China's
population the majority of the people in
China do not eat
those people would consume these smaller
fibers are the rich and powerful a small
minority it's this minority that the
Chinese government chose to favor over
the safety of the rest of the population
is parochial commercial interests of
small Nevada eaters uh hi Jackie
China's National Church soon after the
corona virus outbreak the Chinese
government shut down thousands of wet
markets and temporarily banned wildlife
trade again organizations around the
world have been urging China to make the
ban permanent Chinese social media in
particular has been flooded with
petitions to ban it for good this time
in response China is reportedly amending
the wildlife protection law that
encourage wildlife farming decades ago
but unless these actions lead to a
permanent ban on wildlife farming
outbreaks like this one are bound to
happen again
[Music]
for a bunch more information about
China's wet markets viruses and wildlife
we have an episode on our Netflix show
called the next pandemic explained it
talks about why a Crone virus could
spark the next pandemic and what the
world's experts are doing to stop it
that's on our Netflix show explained
check it out
you